k nearest neighbor is instance based or
lazy learning
that means that you get all the answers
in one big splash
if something changes in your data then
you have to rerun the algorithm from
scratch
this might make it difficult to scale
these models because you're working with
much more data at any one time
sometimes you don't want instance-based
machine learning algorithms
instead you'll want to see a continuous
numerical relationship between different
parts of your data
for that you might use something like
regression analysis
regression analysis looks at the
relationship between predictors
and your outcome sometimes you'll hear
predictors called input variables
independent variables or even regressors
linear regression is one of the most
common types of machine learning
algorithms
with linear regression you'll want to
create a straight line that shows the
relationship between your predictor and
the outcome
you'll want to see all the different
data points closely gathered around the
straight line
then you can make the best prediction of
your outcome
let's think about how this might work
imagine you're an owner of an ice cream
shop
over the last year you've collected 20
days of sales data
then you went out and purchased the
weather data for those days
so with this training data you create a
simple x and y-axis diagram as a scatter
plot
this is when you plot your data along
different parts of your diagram
along the y-axis you list the daily
sales
and along the x-axis you put a
temperature scale
let's say it starts at 60 degrees and
ends at 110 degrees
so you plot all of your different data
points on your diagram
then you'll try to create a line of best
fit
to do this you create a line that splits
your data
this is usually called the hyperplane
sometimes you'll also hear this called
the trend line
so you can see from our scatter plot
diagram that there's a very clear trend
line
the more the temperature goes up the
greater your ice cream sales
you can also see that there's a few
times that you have data points that are
well
outside the trend line this could be
because there was a festival or maybe
just a lot of people wanted ice cream on
a cold day
if you have a lot of data points that
are far away from the trend line
then it will be much more difficult for
you to predict your ice cream sales
as it stands there aren't many outliers
so you can use your linear regression to
predict your sales
let's look at a point in this diagram
let's say that all this week
the weather forecast says it will be
around 95 degrees
now we can look at our hyperplane or
trend line and try to find the
corresponding ice cream sales
you'll see that you can expect to sell
around three thousand dollars
as you can imagine not just ice cream
shop owners are interested in using
machine learning linear regression
in fact if you have more data it's
usually easier to make an accurate trend
line
one interesting about linear regression
is that there are some debate about
whether it's actually machine learning
there's some truth to it because if you
think about it the machine is not
actually learning anything new about the
data
it's just using the data to create a
standard statistical model
it's less about learning and more about
predicting
either way regression is a very popular
way to try and predict future behavior
the key is to find the right predictors
and look for some type of linear
connection with the outcome
you